[Music]
hey everybody it's a cold fall Veterans
Day weekend and I am going to forge
something because gosh darn it it's cold
and I want to be around a fire
so then thinking about what I should
make and I think I want to make like a
boar spear or tried it
probably a boar spear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well guys it's dark it's raining I'm
soaking wet but I'm done and it's not
too bad
knocked out in a couple hours so I'm
going to put this down go get some
dinner
we'll pick this up again another day
well it's been a couple days now I'm
going to hit with the angle grinder
before I heat treat it let's get started
[Music]
well I'm noticing a few things wrong
they missed this tine right here is a
little caca out to the side the neck is
not centered and is a little
asymmetrical and the blade twists a
little bit and there's a few hammer
marks that are really quite deep here
and I'm looking at this going I can't
fix that with the angle grinder so I
think I'm gonna put this down for
tonight and I think tomorrow I might hit
the floor jump stick this back in and
just tweak it a little bit
looking pretty good pretty happy with
how it's turned out so far one problem
though it is warped a little bit it's
just a little caca right here right
where the color change is just kicks off
ever so slightly other than driving my
OCD a little nuts I don't know if it
makes a stitch a difference and if i
reheat treat it I could potentially open
up a lot of other problems so I don't
know if it is worth monkeying with but
I'm gonna think about it while I work on
the wood shaft and by the way a little
bit of coal left over so I made a little
steak knife hey this is the piece of
wood I'm gonna use to make the shaft of
the spear it's 2 inches by 2 inches by
almost 7 feet tall and it's a piece of
teak and the cool thing about this is
this was from a naval old surplus sale
it's left over from restoring the USS
Missouri apparently they redid the the
teak decking on the battleship and this
is an end piece left over a piece of
scrap from restoring the USS Missouri
which was named the Missouri because
that was the home state of President
Truman at the time the USS Missouri was
commissioned and it was the battleship
where they signed the peace treaty
between the u.s. and Japan at the end of
World War two so fun little fact and now
it's gonna make me an awesome bore Speer
all right gotta take a little break got
a jacuzzi being delivered today so thick
is gonna be very happy all right well
there's some takuji get better get back
to work
[Music]
oh ho ho not too bad while I'm working
on this handle I'm mustering up the
courage to reheat and reshape this
spearhead I really want to do this right
so I'll sleep on it pick this up
tomorrow and we're gonna keep working on
this thing well it's another cold day
and we're gonna finish this spear shaft
the heads fine that's ready to go I just
need to take a lot of material off this
handle
[Music]
I love this piece of teak it is an
absolutely gorgeous piece of wood and
will make an awesome spear shaft fits on
really nice life the way it goes
but that warping in the blade is driving
me bonkers once you put it on the shaft
it really sticks out you can really see
that scho mpus I'm terrified I'm gonna
ruin it but I'm doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
something about these projects that I
just love
look at that thing that is huge very
nice piece of wood I really like using
the teak for this handle all right let's
go stab something
I really should have a bunch of
ballistic gel lying around or at least a
big watermelon but I don't but I have a
pile of Osage oranges that's gonna do
okay I had so much fun on this project I
hope you enjoyed this video if you guys
want to see more great foraging videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
check out the link in the description
we've got a whole playlist full of
foraging videos we do all types of
videos and we put out new ones every
Saturday morning don't forget to click
Subscribe and if you want to get
notified make sure to click that Bell
button thanks for watching guys have a
great day wha